Microsoft research brought together
leaders in the exciting field of machine
learning at a major summit in Paris we
are pleased to offer research and focus
interviews with participants at the
Microsoft research machine learning
summit 2013
I'm here with doctor Christopher Bishop
of Microsoft Research Cambridge one of
the co-chairs of the machine and
learning summit now that we've met we
can call each other Chris being here
let's start with the summit talk about
the background of what you're hoping to
accomplish right so the reason we're
having a summit really is because a lot
of people think that the next big thing
in computing is has to do with data so
if you think about the last 40 years of
computing it's really been driven by by
Moore's law by the fact that the number
of transistors on a chip has been
doubling every couple of years and
that's really driven this so this
amazing transformation in the world that
we've seen and what we're seeing today
is something similar is happening with
data the amount of data that we're
collecting and storing is kind of
doubling every couple of years or so and
people think that that data and the
information and the value contained in
that data is going to drive the next
wave of the computing revolution and I
understand right out of the gate you get
some really extraordinary keynote
presentations plan we've got some great
keynote so we're kicking off with Andrew
Blake he's the director of Microsoft
Research Cambridge and he's also a world
expert in computer vision and the field
of computer vision the field of machine
learning I really sort of come together
over the last decade or so so looking
forward some sort of exciting ideas
about the future of vision and the
impact that machine learning will have
from from Andrew then later on we have
Judea pearl Mau Judea has really
pioneered the notion of causality and in
particular learning causality from data
so we know that you know smoking
cigarettes and and getting lung cancer
sort of correlated with each other but
the question is there's one cause the
other was the other cause the one
so getting causality from data is a
really subtle and really hard problem
but a tremendous potential because we
now have all this data in the world we
can in principle discover causal
patterns from the data but it's a hard
thing to do you can't just hit causality
purely from the data alone so we're
looking forward to today as views on on
where we go with this
and our final keynote speaker is Hermann
Hauser now he is one of the founders of
arms so he sold you know more micro
processors and there are people on the
planet and of course that's just the
beginning we're gonna see this explosion
in the number of processes people talk
about the Internet of Things everything
from your coffee cup your wristwatch I
have a processor will be connected to
the Internet so we're going to have tens
of billions of computers connected to
the Internet all gathering and providing
data so this this data explosion
that we see today is really just the
beginning so we you know we're keen to
hear Herman's views on on what all that
those things is gonna do what all those
processes are gonna do for us obviously
some really big topics and you have some
some some big goals for the summer but
let's talk about your work in machine
learning what are you researching the
thing I'm most interested in is there's
a kind of different view of machine
learning from one that we've had for
most of the past I don't know 20 or 30
years so machine learning has quite a
long history and a lot of traditional
methods of machine learning have to do
with you know you gather some input
variables things you measure and you
have some things that you want to Britax
oh you kind of fit a kind of function of
black box between them that takes the
input variables and makes the
predictions and you kind of have a
training phase where you tune up all the
parameters so that works really well and
then you have the sort of the
application phase you provide new inputs
and it makes predictions and that's
great and that's going to be around for
many years to come
and over the last 20 or 30 years a bunch
of different algorithms or techniques
have been developed for solving that
kind of problem so they're very useful
they'll continue to be useful but I'm
interested in a different approach to
machine learning we call it model-based
machine learning so the idea is you've
got a problem you want to solve instead
of choosing one of those standard
algorithms that you hope will solve your
problem instead you build a bespoke
solution you craft a solution that's
that's tailored to your specific
application now it might be that that
bespoke solution happens to be
equivalent to one of those traditional
methods or it might be something
entirely new that's never been done
before so the vision is that you have
some kind of environment within which
you can create a model that is a sort of
a description of the world and or the
piece of the world that you're
interested in in understanding and that
would be did that model be described by
you know 20 30 lines of code no more
some simple compact model and you would
take that model description and this
this platform this environment would
automatically generate an actual machine
code that would do the machine learning
on your data so it's kind of a vision
and we're sort of heart way down the
road and I'm really excited about where
that might go in the years ahead then
you dropped a lot there with the bespoke
in you know the simple code easy for you
to say can we take a look here at
exactly what the secret sauce is okay so
I've got a little demonstration here
little toy example
illustrate a key concept that's going on
here which is the idea of uncertainty so
you know computers are sort of logical
things they deal with Naughton ones on
and off it's all kind of binary
deterministic but the world of data all
has to do with uncertainty with
complexity and with shades of gray if
you like so this is an example of or
this demonstration illustrates the kind
of mathematics that we use as a way of
achieving this vision of model-based
machine learning the basic idea is we're
going to use probabilities to quantify
uncertainty to explain uncertainty so
this little example what it's going to
do is gonna try and recommend some
movies for me to watch so the system has
already been trained on about 10,000
recommendations made by several thousand
people on these 200 movies all it knows
is that you know person 5 liked movie 27
or something like that it doesn't know
that this is an action-adventure or
romantic comedy it doesn't know anything
about the people themselves it's just
likes and dislikes of that set of that
set of people we call that collaborative
filtering but it knows nothing about me
okay so I need to tell it something
let's say I watch a movie let's say I
watch a pretty woman so watch pretty
woman and let's say I like it so I'll
drag it across into the green area to
say I liked that movie what it's done
now is it's rearranged the other movies
on the screen in a particular way now
the vertical position is irrelevant
they're just spread out so we can see
them the horizontal position on the
screen is the the system's probability
that it thinks I will like that movie so
if a movie is down the right hand side
here of the white area it's pretty sure
pretty certain that I like that movie if
it's on the left hand side it's pretty
sure that I won't like the movie and in
the middle it's kind of 50/50 it just
doesn't know okay so what we see now is
the movie it's just kind of down the
middle a little white space down the
edges most of the movies somewhere in
the middle area because it just doesn't
know it doesn't really know what my
likes and dislikes are because all I've
told it is that I like pretty woman I've
given it no more information than that
okay so what we'll do now is we'll give
it a little bit more information so
watch another movie and Sarah watch
Chicago and let's suppose that I didn't
like Chicago okay so I drag it across
here well you see happening is the
movies are kind of spreading out now you
see more movies than the down the sides
it thinks that that unlike ones it
thinks I won't like not so many in the
middle now so that idea of a reduction
in uncertainty when it sees new
information that's that's the view that
we have of machine learning that's what
it means for the machine to learn
something it's uncertainty is reduced so
I'll just count a little bit a little
bit more let's say I don't know I
watched Ocean's Twelve I liked that one
I watched elf I didn't like that one
and you see now we see they're a
different picture we see a lot of white
space down the middle play there are a
few movies it's not sure about but lots
of movies you know it's pretty sure that
I liked them
these ones it's pretty confident though
it won't like them so that's the idea of
learning from data I'll show you one
more little thinner so let's take a
movie down here here's one it's pretty
sure that I like let's say I watch this
and I do like it look what happens
hardly anything okay wasn't surprising
it thought I'd like the movie and I did
so that's unsurprising if I take one
down this side and let's say I watch
this movie it's pretty confident they
won't like it but let's say I do like it
wow we see a big change okay there's a
lot more information because it was a
lot more surprising to the system that I
like that viewing so that notion of
uncertainty is really the the
mathematical basis for doing model-based
machine learning it can be really hard
for me to rent movies from now on it is
I can't just pick one now that I know
this exists so this is obviously an
example of practical application I'm
wondering about areas like healthcare
right so healthcare I think is a
potentially very big area for this
because if we can move to a world where
we have really good electronic health
records where we have the the health
records of millions of people or perhaps
also with genetic information from those
people perhaps also with environmental
information that database could be
enormous we've already made a lot of
advances in medicine from what we call
epidemiology from doing statistics on
data of health care but the the modern
digital world in the world of big data
could allow us to do this on a
completely unprecedented scale so this
could be this could be bigger as big as
you know antibiotics or x-rays in terms
of the history of medicine so I think
there's a tremendous future in that in
that space we're taking a little step
down that road we're working with the
University of Manchester on trying to
understand the factors which affect
aspirin allergies in children so they
a data set of a couple of thousand
children that they've been monitoring
since birth over about the last 11 years
they're collecting all sorts of
variables what we've been doing is
applying these kinds of techniques these
model-based machine learning techniques
as an alternative approach to the
standard statistical methods that are
that are usually used in in the medical
field so we're kind of looking under
different lampposts from everybody else
so we hope we'll find the keys first
let's talk about that as my work I
understand your research students
they're put through a bit of a ritual in
their asthma work right so a lot of we
have research interns they come in the
summer for about three months they're
usually PhDs in computer science in
machine learning they're used to dealing
with data but for them data is often a
sort of a grid you know of numbers that
they see on our on a computer screen and
it's very important when you're doing
machine learning not just to treat the
the data as numbers but to really
understand where it comes from and what
the sort of error processes and the
noise processes are in the data you
really have to understand the domain so
you know the first thing we do with our
interns when when they arrive as we send
them up to Manchester for a few days to
understand the data and what we do is we
actually put them through the same sort
of barrage of techniques that the little
kids have to go through so for instance
the they'll do a skin prick test they
have a whole array of needles put into
their into the into their arm and each
needle has like a little bit of peanut
or cat or dog and extract as it were to
see which ones they're allergic to right
and we measure their lung function we
lock them up in a box and they breathe
in and out we measure the change of
pressure and so on so by the time
they've been through all of this they
have a you know a lot of empathy for
what the kids go through and they
understand you know that that little
number in a table actually you know that
maybe the average of 20 measurements
taken from you know some poor child and
I think that Teddy bender this box and
go through all of this just so we can
get that number so they really learn to
appreciate data it almost sounds like
hazing or in an initiation but obviously
there's a good reason behind it right
you didn't just decide why not know I
think it's tremendously important first
of all to understand the you know the
value of data right the effort that it
requires to get good clean data but also
once you understand where that data came
from you can understand that the data is
not measuring directly the thing you
want to know so you might be measuring
the change of air pressure in some
chamber what you really want to know is
the performance of the child's lung you
can't measure that thing directly you
make an indirect measurement and
modeling the difference between the
thing you can measure and the thing you
want to know is really at the heart of
model-based machine learning and by
modeling that process we hope to get
much better results than if you just
treat that measurement naively as if it
were direct measurement of the thing
you're interested in okay I wonder if
your intern applications are gonna go
down now that they know they got to get
pricked the needles first I don't know I
think you say that